make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and uh
make sure you guys hit the like button
if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back again with another installment
of our beyond omega level series where
we discuss the most powerful characters
in comics and today we are breaking down
a character that is relatively obscure
having only appeared in about three
issues but who is arguably the second
most powerful character in marvel comics
yes this guy is arguably more powerful
than the living tribunal and of course
the character that i'm talking about is
the fulcrum created by daniel noff and
charles noff and first appearing in
eternals number seven in 2009. but
before we get into the fulcrum's first
appearance we need to establish what was
going on with the eternals at the time
and at this point the eternals basically
found themselves in the middle of a
civil war with one side including icarus
makari and cersei who were loyal to
their leader xeros and the other side
who had rebelled against xeros which
included druid and gilgamesh who'd
basically been brainwashed by druid to
murder makari now druid can also destroy
the eternal's activation chambers which
takes away their immortality and so when
makari dies a failsafe is triggered that
will end with all life on earth being
destroyed by an army of cosmic creatures
called the horde now out of desperation
cersei sacrifices herself to resurrect
makari because without him the eternals
cannot communicate with the celestials
and she finds herself in the afterlife
sitting at a bar and talking to a
bartender named jack who informs her
that she is not in heaven or hell but in
a place called the vestibule now he
explains that this is sort of a holding
place for eternals when they die and
either wait to be reborn in an
activation chamber or go on to the place
called lacuna which sounds like the
final destination for the souls of
eternals but it's merely speculation
because jack refuses to describe it with
any more detail now when we see a
conversation between the dreaming
celestial and huawei to the watcher the
dreaming celestial had basically been
visited by makari and it told him that
the preliminary horde was on its way to
earth and he tells uwatu that he is now
experiencing emotions which is not
compatible with his mandate now this
would normally mean that he needed to
shut himself down and compress himself
into a black hole but he says he cannot
do that because he needs to get vital
information concerning earth to the
fulcrum himself but offers no additional
details as to who or what the fulcrum is
now back on earth icarus has gone rogue
and picks a fight with druid in
violation of a treaty that had been
agreed to by drury and zuros now icarus
gets druik's forces to follow him to
alcatraz island which at that time is
where the x-men lived and they joined
the battle on icarus's side in what
seems to be a way to justify putting
wolverine on the cover of the next
eternals issue to basically try and sell
more copies of a book that was about to
get cancelled but anyway the x-men who
really shouldn't be able to put up much
of a fight against the eternals are
actually able to hold their own because
of teamwork i guess but that's really
not that important to the overall story
back in space the dreaming celestial is
confronted by the horde which is making
its way to earth now the celestial tells
the horror that if it tries to attack
him the horde will be punished by the
fulcrum but the horde responds by saying
that the fulcrum will actually punish
the celestial if he doesn't stand aside
so from this exchange we see that the
fulcrum seems to be pulling the strings
of this whole event and that both the
dreaming celestial and the horde are
simply carrying out a plan that was set
in place by the fulcrum and furthermore
that both of these extremely powerful
entities are at the mercy of the fulcrum
that he could destroy any of them if he
wished is a testament to how powerful he
is so the celestial informs the horde
that the amount of life force energy on
earth would exceed the maximum storage
within the horde if it were to harvest
the planet and that if the horde
proceeds with its plan all matter in
this quadrant of the galaxy would simply
be destroyed now the horde then decides
that it will proceed towards earth
anyway bypassing its storage and
channeling all energy it absorbs to the
all high fulcrum the celestial then goes
to inform the fulcrum of the horde's
decision and the horde arrives on earth
which forces the eternals to stop
fighting amongst themselves and turn
their attention to the horde before it
destroys all life on earth as not even
celestials are able to stop them and so
to do this they decide they need to come
together to form the unimine which will
allow them to take over the body of the
dreaming celestial in order to do that
however the eternals have to select a
prime eternal and when xeros shows up
with the rest of the group they decide
to make icarus the prime eternal and the
unimine takes over the dreaming
celestial's body but while this goes on
the celestial's consciousness is still
talking to uwatu who informs the
celestial that he has developed free
will which he uses to allow the unimine
to inhabit his body to fight the horde
while his consciousness goes to appeal
directly to the fulcrum and spare earth
now when we see the dreaming celestial
enter the vestibule and start talking
with jack the bartender who's revealed
to actually be the fulcrum he tells the
fulcrum about the changes to his
programming his development of emotions
and a conscience and asked the fulcrum
to spare earth from the horde now the
fulcrum agrees on the condition that the
celestial can answer two questions the
first simply being why to which the
celestial responds because i care and
the fulcrum commends tiamou for being
the first in the history of time to ever
ascend to question the fulcrum's will
and become a free-thinking celestial he
then declares the celestial to be as
equal and asks his second question which
is whether the celestial will come with
him to destroy the horde and then we get
to see this epic battle with the fulcrum
and the dreaming celestial fighting side
by side to take down the world devouring
horde just kidding we've seen nothing
the story jumps forward over a hundred
years into the future with the eternals
once again in hiding however one of them
joey athena the son of the eternal
athena has been located by michelle
urich the granddaughter of the daily
bugle reporter ben urich and he just
tells her that the fulcrum restored all
the damage done by the horde and set
everything right and that no one even
remembered the horde's attack and that's
really all we know about the fulcrum
because like i said he's only appeared
in three issues that make up this story
arc now some have theorized that the
fulcrum is actually not a separate
entity but instead is simply one aspect
of the one above all and they point to
the fact that he takes the form of a man
named jack and the one above all was
once depicted as being jack kirby but
there's really nothing in these issues
that indicates the fulcrum has anything
to do with the one above all except
maybe that he is referred to as the all
high by the horde but either way the
fact that he is pretty much omnipotent
in the sense that the celestials and the
horde both of which are cosmically
powerful beings answer directly to him
earns him a spot on our beyond omega
level series but with that being said
let me know what you guys think right do
you want to see more of the fulcrum do
you think he should appear more i'm kind
of curious maybe i think he's one of
those characters who just needed to be a
one-off and that's it there's no real
purpose in having his character return
but let me know what you guys think
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace